today the argument for equality of
outcome is all the rage institutions
across america are lowering the
standards so that we can all be equal in
the end but you know what that really
means we're all equal on the bottom
[Music]
hello my name is pastor corey brooks and
i'm still here that's right on the south
side of chicago on this rooftop living
in this tent right behind me for 100
days from november the 20th to february
28th bringing awareness to the violence
in chicago but also trying to raise
enough money to build a much needed
community center on this block that we
call o block
o named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs picked
up his name and started calling it
o-block well we decided we want to keep
the o but we want to call it
opportunity block
today i want to talk about
the equality of opportunity today the
argument for equality of outcome is all
the rage institutions across america are
lowering the standards so that we can
all be equal in the end but you know
what that really means we're all equal
on the bottom
that's not what we're fighting for on
the south side in another impoverished
neighborhoods across america whether
they be brown black or asian whatever if
equity is what we're fighting for then
we may all we may as all well as lay
down and give up because there is no
american dream without the equality of
outcome that's why we're fighting so
hard for equality of opportunity see
what very few people realize on the
south side is that since the 1960s our
government post 60s liberalism has made
us an experiment in this pursuit for
equality of outcome our community is
literally government controlled we have
every form of government assistance
available from housing food medical care
the outcome after 60 and 70 years of
this is that we are all equal on the
bottom the american dream is very dim
for where i sit we can blame the
government the post-60 liberalism as we
want to but the sad thing is that we in
this community allowed it to happen what
is even worse is that we have had
generations after generations born into
this world and this is all they know
just like the world is all you know we
have to educate them to understand that
this is not acceptable we also have to
educate them to know that the change is
possible we come from a proud people who
survive the worst of american horrors
and we can reverse the conditions in our
neighborhoods the first thing we must
accept is that government has no
interest in the ability to fix the
damage it did to our communities we must
do it ourselves this is why i've made it
my mission on the south side of chicago
to fight the equality of opportunity the
fight begins with ourselves american
history is full of people who say things
don't have to be the way they are we
must fight for the change today on the
south side we must add to that legacy if
our public schools are not equal to
schools on other neighborhoods then we
must hold our educators accountable if
crime makes us too afraid to go out then
we must fight for the right to protect
ourselves and we must also break the
codes of this street and help the police
reel the neighborhoods of those keeping
us down from the almighty dollar i could
go on and on but you get the point the
pursuit of equality of opportunity
begins with us we must awaken our spirit
we must take the first step and we must
have we must be taking the first step
for years project good we've been taking
those steps we've been helping countless
of people pursue the path of equality
opportunity to be to succeed pursuing
equality the outcome
that is why we must pursue the equality
of opportunity with everything that we
have it is our daily hope our universal
hope
that is why we strive so desperately to
make sure that we have the equality of
opportunity
you